welcome to this video playing that she
chose probably mispronouncing that yeah
let's see how do we want to get a winnin
yeah i was on 25 something and then lost
two games in a row destroying destroying
my chance to get to the all time I'm
okay let's see what this guys doing here
Kings Indian and takes on deform yeah
that's a pretty decent line for black
nothing that gives why too much this is
actually when I when I was still playing
the Kings Indian with black how I played
against Bishop e3
57 looks kind of weird yeah that was
this idea just wants to check that might
be three I can also just take si
six-sided looks look that looks a bit
lame that's that may be okay making make
a play a 5 a-5 a form i cannot take d 5
at the moment now that might be might be
the case okie h1 maybe wasn't idea i
don't know i don't like 9 p-3 that much
know that i had a bit of a time to
reflect on that okay let's do this for
security reasons to see what to do here
and just to be safe on the diagonal
there they don't want to fall too far
behind on the clock here might be five
to four is an idea
now maybe I can annoy him a little bit
with that pin the most a six is
definitely not on blacks agenda he can
yeah he displayed any way it looks
terribly weakening like night a4 b6 but
maybe he has some concrete justification
for the move d for some kind of tactic
that's maybe possible default no it
doesn't go for anything special hmm I
can also play Bishop g3 in this position
sending him somewhere to d7 back off and
whatever i def will be 6 let's go for
that go them okay
char maybe the night is not that great
down be 60 that that can actually be the
case want to prepare also before him
stabilize my pawn and threatening to
take that a couple of times oh is this
not a big threat probably not not at the
moment
what is the idea arrest oh he needs some
specific idea to justify the trades
otherwise this is just something that I
like to see of course gaining control
them I can take the five is this I
cannot sorry I'm f4 of course now I can
go back though and keep this idea for
later
295 don't see why not actually 9594 97
it's possible why not don't see why not
and through the night f6 so it's not
that you can just move the Queen
anywhere Stan pick point here is night
see two at the end maybe this is the the
point
maybe down check 96 sb7 as a checked and
chow it's kind of disappointing that I
didn't didn't get more out of that III
III m maybe it's still enough though I
get get both parts that will be nice
there were some funny tactics we have to
check that later
c6 bishop I'm just promoting or not why
why am I not just promoting I'm just
promoting the podium night there and
night a seven black resigns hmm that was
a bit of a bit of a strange game yeah I
was surprised that he just agreed to and
to all of those trades like like that
because he has to he has to justify that
with some kind of concrete play
otherwise I will just have the better
position him and it didn't really do
much night F form I was thinking he
should fight 4d for here like I think I
thought of that one like night f5 maybe
a deform this is I know maybe I'm clear
I don't know this so that 95 I would
take but maybe he can play like this now
that's it's not clear this position he
has some chances their computer things
its equal yeah I know it gets very very
tricky and but this is this is maybe not
the best way to play then with hindsight
I did not see that night see two at the
end was happening the comp just wants to
play Queen d1 and says why this is
clearly better one point is that I'm
threatening g4 with the winner of this
Bishop so it's really funny it has no
squares interesting and it was better
than but okay I'm still keeping an
advantage it share
check the weird thing was that well here
takes takes I was I was really wondering
here why he was thinking he should take
but here i was i was thinking night at
hi bishop a6 my twin right yeah it does
this is the tactic that i mentioned in
the during the game that this tactic
wins it's a typical thing that sometimes
happens if the night tries to stop upon
it is just too slow a piece to do so and
he I'm winning I'm getting this pawn for
winning end game yeah this is why I
could not take a to him and went down
yam and I mean this is a bit tougher I
was thinking night here cheeks cheeks
probably and this he can try to hold my
ponies it's not promoting and to my king
is very far away his sis King is a bit
quicker he still probably has good
drawing chances yeah I'm not totally
sure without deep analysis this I think
is just this is just losing I get simply
give get too many bit too much material
there okay well thanks for watching